moi je continue à penser qu'il y a hall
et au micro je ne sais pas parce
qu'encore une fois le les travaux qui
sont plus publiés actuellement sur léoni
qu'on ne montre pas d'efficacité
vaccinale significative d'accord pour et
en général les gens jusqu'à 50 ans il
n'ya pas d'en boire dans lequel on voit
en particulier à aider les gens
développer une surmortalité depuis deux
ans lié à ce virus donc ça peut faire
partie d'une stratégie de lutte contre
l'épidémie mais on peut pas dire aux
gens vous mettez votre propre santé en
danger en ne vous vaccinant pas nous on
a l'impression de la décrochent avant je
disais 60 ans ou 65 ans on a
l'impression que ça décroche à pâtir de
54 ans c'est à dire que les risques de
faire quelque chose d'un peu plus graves
à partir de 54 ans sont sont aussi
critiques et puis bien entendu les gens
qui sont obèses présentent un risque on
sait que c'est à la fois l'âge et
l'obésité qui font le risque de cette
maladie la deuxième chose c'est sur le
plan épidémique est ce que on a une
évidence que ça sert à quelque chose
c'est çà et là répond je suis désolé pas
être d'accord avec les autorités avec
les autorités la réponse c'est non cela
ne contrôle pas l'épidémie pas du tout
ces pays dans lequel a fait plus de
vaccins ya le plus de cas alors que
c'est pas contrôler l'épidémie pour des
raisons de son complexe à expliquer
scientifiquement
peut-être même que dans un certain
nombre de cas il ya une chose que les
gens n'avaient pas regarder qui est très
importante c'est le nombre de cas
d'infections qui suit dans les quinze
jours à trois semaines une injection
vaccinale et ça c'est probablement dû à
un phénomène scientifique qui avaient
été insuffisamment analyser et une
épidémiologie insuffisamment fed qui
sont les anticorps facilitant c'est à
dire qu'il ya des anticorps qui facilite
l'infection et que leur effet se voit
dans les trois semaines qui suivent une
inflexion donc justement parce que alors
vous dites que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec les les autorités qu'il ya
président emmanuel macron qui organisait
une conférence de presse
ah voilà aujourd'hui et qui disait qui
revenue sur la polémique emmerder les
non vaccinés il dit être citoyen savoir
des droits et des devoirs et ce sont
d'abord des devoirs le concept de
liberté s'arrête là où la liberté de
l'autre est entravée là où la vie de
l'autre peut-être en danger il a déclaré
en précisant que c'était ma
responsabilité de sonner l'alarmé des
propos qu'il assume totalement rappelant
qu'être citoyen savoir des droits et des
devoirs voilà donc il est il est revenue
à dessus
voilà qu'est ce que tu fous vous savez
ça nous a choqués c'est cette phrase sur
emmerder les non vaccinés
c'est au monde pourrait choquer pour
quoi que ce soit mais globalement il n'y
a pas d'évidence que les gens non
vaccinées soit plus contagieux que les
genres action n'a pas si on regarde les
charges virales je sais qu'on a essayé
de nous chanter les choses qui sont
totalement fausse pour le delta pour le
delta d'une manière paradoxale les gens
qui étaient vaccinés avait des charges
virales plus importante que l'on ne
l'était pas maxime donc il n'y a pas
d'évidence actuellement de contrôle mais
je comprends bien que les gens qui
estime devoir contrôler cette épidémie
se servent de ce qu'ils ont cela étant
on ne peut pas accuser là on arrive même
heureusement je crois qu'ils vont pas le
faire dans le chu mais on arrive à un
espèce de paradoxes qui a été évoqué la
dent les autorités du chu qui m'a foutu
dehors je sais ce que c'est que il
proposait que les gens vaccinés
asymptomatique et personnels de soins
vacciner asymptomatiques puisse venir à
l'hôpital soigner mais pas les
non-vaccinés asymptomatique et là on
arrive on fait culminer la déraison qui
est je sais ce qui est bien et je me
fous de la science mais moi je ne me
fous pas de la science